okay good do you still feat that Al's
gonna braise my fanny pack
we're playing layers of fear it's a
brand new horror game about making a
painting and there's jump scares
everywhere let's keep playing
I'll pick this house Jesus Christ
hello oh my favorite floor the one that
has floor turned out to be a kind of a
pun
hello we get I'm gonna leave that open
so no one can steal my elevator hater
goddamn hate this one is beyond my
elevators that's pretty good all right
we're store brass hula do lead off king
kelana COFF COFF Alana pink upon it will
it do it this one good job bro so you
did nothing
oh god great just great
oh my god with the actual [ __ ] no I
heard someone fart over here yeah oh oh
I smell it it's too quiet there's gonna
be a jumps hello it's too quiet
it's too [ __ ] quiet baby but baby but
missed you ma you're my favorite ah what
am I doing here
great Nate Oh No hello why did you stop
that dude was perfect honey please just
a little longer at least until I finish
painting
Martin oh don't make me beg
beautiful I gotta say I'm impressed by
the way this game is oh my god
innovative and has an interesting story
that doesn't take away from the
immersion it's very impressive someone I
really enjoy it this is probably one of
the best horror games I've played in a
long time so far all right you know I'm
not gonna judge the dogs I asked until I
sniffed it am i right I think we're good
here I think we did whoo
oh yeah we got a key Berenice oh I'm
smelling something you really have to be
on guard for this one huh hello there
hello Oh
you look good you look real good all
right so we're just gonna keep going
how [ __ ] big it's my house all right
let's just keep going I don't know what
to tell you why do I bother closing the
doors hey I've seen you before and yeah
I say you hey that's not you know and I
was I can zoom in on the pictures
thumbnail no thank you
Jesus Christ it's wrong with this game
oh god it's so dark
Oh Jeff daddy bison what hey walk
through the mirror
hello yeah
what what fire I oh god is she
which hospital I'm on my way you can
stop bringing now I'm gonna go back in
the mirror now damn it
listen I am Surya
what do you want from me well I had a
great interior designer it's with a my's
noises alright don't appreciate that
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you mice so our wife
or kid died in a fire
sounds like it cooks hidden in the door
what a [ __ ] bummer here we go
proud of myself and this drawer and this
painting great painting love it let's
just keep going out of the room fine I'm
fine don't worry alright I write I write
I'm just gonna [ __ ] no no shut up the
[ __ ] was that a fan Bros I told you not
to do this many times I told you say
hello okay hello hello we're good okay
hey do you still fit that that [ __ ] is
your problem
yes PC stupid stupid chair you don't
know me you don't know me chair what are
you what do you want I'm sorry oh no
don't you dare follow me [ __ ] [ __ ]
locked me in what Jack
I hate chairs what are you looking at
mr. chair nope it doesn't count shut up
no don't [ __ ] tease me you [ __ ] huh
what did I say what is going on here
stop stop this nonsense at Vons what
this is is this where I sleep I would
love to sleep look I have a pee bucket
and everything I love it this is a great
house my favorite house my house that's
locked that's just great fine I'll go
back to where I once
don't judge me you're an [ __ ] you
have an ugly haircut too not you you
have a beautiful hair and probably
beautiful face I swear I swear to God
okay this is going great enjoy this all
right well the doors are still locked so
I don't really know what to tell you
right now there's there's a box here
just in case and the sock sock box
it's my favorite found you what is what
is that sound
[Applause]
what
[Music]
it's the painting following me what you
dick
oh oh oh this house is amazing
yeah I'm Akay those stairs leg of mine I
think you'll have to carry me to the
bedroom once we move in mine god there's
something following in Lacombe oh great
what I want it yes Matt I need it
what happened if it's the hardest you're
right well the first step is the hardest
so the second one is sure is [ __ ]
hell ain't easier [ __ ] stored better
not feeling it's with the whisk Springs
hello you know I can [ __ ] hear you
jack
stop what do you want
ah I'll play music a bit about that the
depth at that better be some art Kelly
or some nicki manaj or some [ __ ] alright
well feel better put prostheses
Snatchers why the damn leg can't afford
a new one
I guess we lost our leg from the keq am
i right ladies naked let's let's [ __ ]
pop that [ __ ] shut up
I play them what kind of music I want I
don't care if it's not hipster
laugh at that oh good good got a leak I
think we got a little thing back it's
playing backwards my god it's oh my god
Margaret this is gonna be a mess to
clean up Margaret God what is this I
needed a jar and a plastic tubing i
siphon I gas before I knew how it was
done I stuck the tube in a vein and
sucked on it until blood filled my mouth
then put the tube in the jar and it just
kept coming the taste of copper haunted
me the entire night why think of a
syringe
why didn't I think of a syringe huh are
you out of your goddamn mind what do the
doctor just say about straining yourself
you can barely hold a cold damn thing Oh
are we good
again yes yes just just the painting
leaked a little bit but ain't no leakage
without a problem no hello how yes
another piece of the puzzle salt high
fives life's painted baby whatever gap
what do we got give me give me more give
me more give me it's really taking a
nice little shape it looks like a demon
from hell
very nice very nice heart that would say
good chant good chant good check way
better than that other we unlocked so
each of these is a piece of the Piersol
first I looked for a canvas oh yeah no
we said this and then there was a blood
this is so creepy
look at me I'm beautiful you don't know
you're beautiful
am i limping I could be sure does look
like it isn't it if only you saw what I
can see you'd understand why I want you
so desperately you're limping is what
makes you make me wanna pee beautiful
how's everyone doing that's not allowed
to go there apparently
oh why God why
let's go here great fantastic hi this
looks like a great room great lamp I
love that what does it say I don't think
we know there is what no don't [ __ ] with
my god damn it
Oh what stop Jesus no oh god it's this
floor
Oh God room this Oh God I've got four
hello hi hi hey put a pie here - [ __ ]
just want to go wouldn't drink a
smoothie guys I have super strength
just what I'd hope for a life live your
laugh and be free this is going great
restless memories nay nay
it's refine yeh alright forget that's
not the screaming thing screaming dead
demon I'll call it again god dammit hey
my game is [ __ ] with your mind got my
mind on my game in my game doesn't
really make sense of this ah back here
great great
reminds me a PT doesn't it hey babbit i
bap bap we came from there that [ __ ]
don't make no sense
am i right ladies up top that's right
you know what I'm talking about
don't pretend you know
[ __ ] me let's go in here Oh God
oh it's potato man potato man I'm misty
man
how you been tell me everything
gentlemen gentlemen you're not giving me
answers I need answers now I've got time
for this potato man I got a life and I
need a living you have a potato and you
need a filling you have inserted a
minute thought we had something potato
man I thought we were a thing [ __ ] you
then potato me dick clearly missing a
piece of them we're missing the potato
damn it we're close we're close damn it
but you have to fail to not try right
yes stay get it how's that one doing
yeah all right beautiful outside today
isn't it reminds me of waste ah hope
kills the mine well what's that a squirt
let me hear that again that is
definitely a little bit in the end yeah
I like it I like it
everyone likes a little yeah I'm right
ladies take me yeah
yes Oh doing great
proudest of the proud boom badda boom
badda boom we're doing great so good
this is a really cool game I'm really
enjoying it all right let's go out
what's everyone doing well see I know
that I know your tricks now game you
can't scare me anymore like a bath think
I'm scared of that Oh God
oh [ __ ] me oh oh [ __ ] safe
silent floaters they clog the drains in
the water no a baby in the bath baby
the baby and the babe in the bath the
baby bear have maybe had a baby in the
bath oh great great
well great great yes my [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh God not the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] no
not the [ __ ] men okay thank God we have
a light okay Oh God
[ __ ] me in the ass please don't hello I
am definitely limping I can tell now
I'll walk in the stairs head out there's
someone there
oh my god it's so blurry I turn on the
lights please
okay what it is is lamb this is fine
yeah no this is great I'm enjoying this
[Music]
mannequin collection go I'm in a what is
up with that
[Music]
what all right you're flying pants I'm
flying
Jesus Christ look at this gorgeous
I am jamming out whoa that's cool man
that's pretty cool
okay [ __ ] your chair I mean the table
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this
this is so weird what whoo
can't [ __ ] with me [ __ ] you tables and
[ __ ] it's my jam zero-gravity Jam bra
just reckon this I'm a wrecking ball wow
that [ __ ] hurt I needed to remove the
flesh for your bone
oh my god first I was lost as to how but
then I sawed it off with a handsaw
boiled it then put the bone in a mortar
what that [ __ ] obviously this was not
something I done before finally I mixed
dust of some white paint it made for a
lovely undercoat
and here we are that's piece number
three let's put it price ah we're gonna
have to end that episode there thank you
so much for all the amazing support in
this series it's been so cool so far
really amazing horror game and I really
hope you bros are enjoying it as much as
I am if you are go ahead and leave a
like right now so it's gotta come
birthday and I'll see you in the next
one as always stay awesome ha ha I'm
ready